I think the only decent thing that Tori
back benchers could do now is call time
on list trust and this entire UK
government and allow people across the
UK to have a general election I mean
this is beyond a joke it was never funny
but list trust has already through her
own decisions crashed the economy and
heaped misery on people who were already
struggling with the cost of living
crisis now today she has fought her
Chancellor to carry the can for her
decisions so she had already shown
herself to be completely out of her
depth as prime minister as of today she
is also a lame duck prime minister the
sooner she goes and the sooner people
get the chance to get rid of this Tory
government that is doing so much damage
once and for all the better of course
the only way for Scotland to permanently
get rid of Tory governments we don't
vote for is through Independence
at all in the last week or so no I mean
let's trust hasn't phoned me as first
minister of Scotland she hasn't phoned
Matt Draper just first minister of Wales
so even on these basic courtesies of
government we are political opponents
but we should be working together where
we can constructively that's what I have
done with Liz truss's three predecessors
in my time as first minister so even on
these basic things she has shown herself
unfit to hold the Office of Prime
Minister now that would be one thing if
that was just you know a sort of
political issue and all we were dealing
with right now was political cycle drama
uh that's not a good thing but it is
made so much more serious right now that
the price of list trust's incompetence
and ideological uh you know
determination to drive through damaging
policies the price of that has been paid
by people the length and breadth of the
UK people who are already struggling
with the cost of living crisis are now
facing soaring mortgage rates and the
cost of borrowing going up it is
unconscionable what in just a month or
so in office list trust has done to the
UK economy and to the living standards
of people in every part of the UK it's
time for her to go it's time for this
entire UK government to go and for
people across the UK to get the
opportunity to have their say in a
general election well let's just says
Adam and she's she's you know going to
be staying on this is a government
you're going to have to work with if she
were to pick up the phone to you tonight
what would your message to her be it
resign but beyond that look I am not the
the block to a constructive relationship
with the UK government let's trust is
the fourth prime minister that has been
in office since I have been first
Minister I have a deep political
differences obviously with her three
predecessors but I've managed to work
constructively to a greater or lesser
extent with all of them and the fact
that that relationship hasn't even got
past first base with list trust is not
down to me frankly nor is it down to
Mark Drakeford in Wales it's down to Liz
trust being out of her depth and unfit
to hold the Office of Prime Minister and
now we saw Boris Johnson been unfit for
very different reasons list trust hasn't
even managed to show a basic level of
competence in the job and as I said a
moment ago if that was just an abstract
problem that would be one thing but the
price of that incompetence has been paid
by people right now in the value of
their mortgage repayments gone up every
month and the cost of living crisis that
people are already struggling with this
can't go on it's not sustainable and the
sooner we see the back of less trust and
that entire Tory government the better
for everybody